THEY DROPPED AN EARLIER AND THEN
WENT TO THE BUDGET THAT WOULD
HAVE RENEWED THE TAX BREAK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALREADY
CALLED THE OPIOID ABUSE EPIDEMIC
OF CRISIS.
TODAY THE ADMINISTRATION BROUGHT
TOGETHER A WIDE ARRAY OF PEOPLE
DETERMINED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE HAS
MORE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WE ARE WITH YOU 100%.
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR YOU, AND
WE'RE GOING TO WIN.
>> TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE IT
CLEAR THAT AS FIGHTS GO, THIS
ONE IS ONLY THE FIRST ROUND.
>> IF YOU WANT TO BE WE CAN TALK
ABOUT BLUE-RIBBON COMMITTEES,
THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE STRENGTH AND
TOUGHNESS.
>> THE GATHERING, A FOLLOW-UP TO
LAST OCTOBER WHEN THE PRESIDENT
DECLARED THE CRISIS OF
NATIONWIDE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
>> AS AMERICANS, WE CANNOT ALLOW
THIS TO CONTINUE.
IT'S TIME TO LIBERATE OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM THIS SCOURGE OF
DRUG ADDICTION.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAS EMBARKED
ON A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO
TACKLE THE PROBLEM.
EDUCATION AND PREVENTION,
TREATMENT AND RECOVERY, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTRODUCTIONS.
THE LATTER PRODUCED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S FIRST EVER
INDICTMENTS AGAINST CHINESE
FUNCTIONAL MANUFACTURERS.
NATIONAL TAKE BACK DAY.
A RECORD 456 TONS OF EXPIRED AND
UNAIDED PUSHPIN DRUGS COLLECTED.
CRITICS HAVE ACCUSED THE
ADMINISTRATION OF DOING LITTLE
TO CHANGE THE LIVES OF THOSE
IMPACTED.
A SPOKESMAN WRITING "ACTIONS
SPEAK A LOT LOUDER THAN WORDS.
WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES ON THE LINE
EACH DAY, TRANSACTIONS SAY HE
DOES NOT TAKE THIS CRISIS
SERIOUSLY."
TO SOME THE OPIOID BATTLE AS A
POLITICAL ONE.
THE CRISIS HAS HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON RURAL
AMERICANS.
AND OFTEN OVERLOOKED PART OF THE
ELECTORATE THAT HELPED PROPEL
THE PRESIDENT OFFICE.
OR IN THE CASE OF STATES LIKE
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND MINNESOTA,
NEARLY DID.
>> WHERE YOU HAVE THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF ABUSE IS EXACTLY WHERE
HIS FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN LIVE
HIS FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN LIV
LIVE.
THEY ARE GOING TO SAY YES, GOOD
FOR MY MAN DONALD.
HE IS PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
PROBLEMS MY NEIGHBORS HAVE.
>> FOR CONTACTS, AND 2016,
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOST
NEW HAMPSHIRE BY FEWER THAN
3,000 VOTES.
HE CAME WITHIN A PERCENTAGE AND
A HALF OF WINNING MINNESOTA,